I have to tell you Michael Bloomberg is
doing something absolutely hilarious
because it shows how easily trigger able
Donald Trump is Michael Bloomberg is
trolling Donald Trump about his weight
remember that this is something Trump is
very trigger about about by all serious
accounts Donald Trump is clinically
obese now he officially claims to be six
foot three inches tall and weigh 239
pounds if true that puts him like a
pound below clinically obese but nobody
believes that height Trump is pictured
in net in a number of pictures he's
standing next to people known to be
shorter than six three and Trump is very
clearly shorter than them so we know
this is a very sensitive topic for
Donald Trump the alpha male this is an
ad that Michael Bloomberg put together
where he specifically uses what are
known as fat pics of Donald Trump
playing golf now I'm not calling them
fat pics pejoratively these are specific
pictures of Donald Trump playing golf
and like an all-white very light khakis
and a white shirt where he is known to
be absolutely furious when these
pictures are used because okay he looks
extremely large in them and Trump
doesn't like looking this way check it
out it even includes a picture of Trump
looking visibly exhausted and sort of
climbing to reach what looks like an
errant golf ball that he shot off the
course take a look people have said when
you were mayor the city gave Trump a
contract to operate a golf course yes
that's true but he was the only bidder
and running a golf course is the only
job that I would hire them for I'm like
I approve this message it is now being
reported by Charlie Gasperi no no
left-wing bomb thrower he's a reporter
for box Fox Business Network that the
Bloomberg ads wid the so-called fat pics
have made Trump furious and that he's
been melting down privately and also
tweeting endlessly about Michael
Bloomberg who he has dubbed mini Mike
Trump tweeting in close succession quote
mini Mike is part of the fake news they
are all working together in fact
Bloomberg isn't covering himself to
boring to do or other Dems only Trump
that sounds fair it's all the fake news
media and that's why nobody believes in
them anymore
continuing to focus on mini Mike saying
quote many of the ads you were watching
were paid for by mini Mike Bloomberg he
is going nowhere just wasting his money
but he is getting the DNC to rig the
election against crazy Bernie something
they wouldn't do for Cory Booker and
others they are going to do it again to
Bernie 2016 and then once again and this
one is actually hilarious Trump tweeting
so triggered mini mic is now negotiating
both to get on the Democrat primary
debate stage and to have the right to
stand on boxes or a lift during the
debates this is sometimes but not really
fair that is absolutely hilarious the
stuff Trump comes up with when he gets
triggered is so funny he also did
something Trump did that he rarely does
if ever which is he tweeted about
exercising now remember Donald Trump is
the guy who believes that when the human
body exercises it depletes some total
amount of energy that you have at your
disposal for life and so he's not a guy
who brags about exercising and yet after
the fat pick ad came out Donald Trump
tweeting a picture of himself golfing
with a caption getting a little exercise
this morning so regardless of
Bloomberg's chances and the chances
aren't great although I do believe it's
possible Mike Bloomberg could end up
third in delegates one if he continues
the strategy that we've outlined a
couple of weeks ago this is just
fantastic I would love to see Bloomberg
also do some ads that are compilations
of Trump
slurred speech you know the United
States of America god bless the USA the
Israeli city of faroush ylim and that
that type of thing whoever is doing
these knows exactly what the trigger
points are for Donald Trump and is
exploiting them I saw that the Bloomberg
campaign is hiring some data science
people here in Massachusetts probably
another Super Tuesday States as well
clearly Bloomberg is not being shy about
laying out the cash and we can expect a
lot of action from Bloomberg I just hope
there's more of these ads that are
triggering Trump visibly on Twitter last
thing to clarify I'm not making fun of
obesity nor do I find it funny it's a
serious medical condition what I'm
pointing out is that the supposed alpha
male Trump who's the best at everything
both eats a terrible diet doesn't
exercise and is so easily trigger Abul
when you hit certain pressure points and
Michael Bloomberg is taking advantage of
those one of our sponsors is privacy
calm they're giving you $5.00 when you
sign up for their completely free
service at privacy calm slash Pakman
I've been using privacy for a little
over a year now you've heard me talk
about it before it's a lifesaver and
here's how it works takes just a couple
of minutes to set up anytime you buy
something online or on the phone instead
of actually using your real credit card
number the privacy app and the browser
plugin let you give each company a
randomized virtual credit card number
that you create out of thin air it'll
even autofill the card number with one
click and the payment is taken out of
your checking account without the
merchant ever knowing your real
information so this allows you to keep
your banking information secure but also
to take control of your finances you can
create up to 12 of these virtual credit
cards a month you can set spending
limits you can freeze them you can
delete them anytime you want so when you
do this it means you're not going to be
charged when you don't want to be
because you can destroy the virtual card
number right after using it which for
instance I love using free trials
because I know I won't be charged when
the trial is over if I use a virtual
credit card number
you're keeping your identity private by
not telling companies who you are you're
keeping your bank or credit card info
protected against data breaches and
identity theft and it's free there's no
catch whatsoever but if you want privacy
also offers a $10 a month plan that
gives you one percent cashback and lets
you create 36 credit cards a month and a
$25 a month plan tailored more for small
businesses where you can create 60 card
numbers a month and much more
but definitely go ahead and at least get
started with a free plan you'll protect
your financial info companies can't
charge you unexpectedly and like I said
you'll get $5 to spend when you sign up
at privacy calm / Pakman